the solution is something that we've
seen in the previous examples
in order to update the moved or vector
we query the state of the move up move
down left and right actions and adjust
the movement vector accordingly once
this is done we can test whether or not
the length of the vector is equal to
zero or not this gives us the ability to
determine if the user's even pressed a
key if the user hasn't pressed a key
then the length of move dir will
actually be zero we can test this with
the length squared function that allows
us to then only call normalize and
multiply when the user has pressed a
movement key and of course all of this
data after being computed gets funneled
into set leaner velocity so that we can
then move our fancy awesome robot into
the future now that we have the ability
to move the player around the world
using keys the next step is to figure
out how they actually fire their fancy
missiles towards the other robots